we hang out uh yes wishes but we have
boozy three-hour dinners we do
uh and um you've been uh you're always
working on the next thing i know you've
been
for you worked on your biden yeah in
case he became president he did and you
have a very good you have some good
observations as an impressionist
tell us about biden but yeah biden well
i watched him during when he's doing the
town hall
and that's where i kind of got him
because he would walk around with the
microphone really slow
yeah my father you know lost his job no
kidding not joking around
there's nothing funny at all about his
dad losing his job but is it
my dog died i'm not kidding around
joe i found a severed head no joke no
kidding
that was the first hook no joke i'm not
kidding around here man
and then i noticed he made lists number
one the one part number two the thing
number three you know the drill because
he gets confused and then he kind of
turns on the audience come on isn't
rocket science
i mean i beat up a guy you know named
corn pop
i beat him up corn pop pop pop popcorn
jiffy pop anyway
excuse me children of the corn so those
were the three homes did you see
he biden just met did you i just met
with putin oh yeah
that you know to me putin is like is an
interesting idea of a dictator is going
to be there for 30 years talk a new guy
might be gone in two years yeah
so he's like it's just he's like the guy
who swallowed the cat right oh
it's our electoral system people calm
down
yeah and putin is just so smooth with it
now you just had trump a minute ago
now he's got nah so he's like
and the interpreter is like we're going
to keep our ballistic missiles in the
ukraine and biden's like come on give it
come on
get your facts straight jack let's do
some footage
come on take you out behind the woodshed
and beat the hell out of you
i was talking to you uh it was the day
it was the day
after the obamas signed a netflix deal
yeah and i just happened to i think we
got lunch or something and you were just
tickled to death that the obamas were
going to be working with netflix
and you started making me laugh so hard
talking about it
do you remember when we were pitching
movies and stuff i i do obama a lot of
my podcasts i just have
i just love his i love i love the
character
of a guy kind of is that cool that calm
you can just kind of
sum things up that's all and even
so he i had the idea i go to netflix
just to meet with him i would love to
pitch him but i assume he
might have an idea for me because he's
new then i got an idea before you start
i don't know it's a half hour show i
think it's um it's about guys in a bar
they're all
friends it's called uh here's to you i
go i think that's cheers oh [ __ ] me
michelle
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and i always have him yelling at
michelle michelle he didn't like it
didn't want it
i got another one okay that one didn't
work this one's a big boat sinks i'm
calling it gigantic
i think that's titanic oh hey michelle
he didn't watch that
leave show egg salad out on the table
i'll eat it when i get to it
so i just do him a lot i love i love the
candy he's got that great cause
that is kind of everything you know you
say things are going good
you got to be happy that's right conan
o'brien there you go
[Laughter]
andy richter enough said that's it
that's all you got to be you don't have
to try to be anything other than what
you are
america appreciates and loves the two of
you
i feel i feel better thank you mr
president
yeah well yeah that's the thing is there
are different kinds of
impressionists and some go for
incredible
accuracy and you do this thing where you
you're kind of interested in accuracy
and rhythm but you're more interested
in stretching it out yeah which is the
kind of impressions
i've always loved to see people do you
you almost stretch it out like silly
putty
until it becomes almost it's not quite
the person but you're capturing
something
it's kind of like your arnold was became
well that's only i i just watched you
doing arnold but we both
blew it out to this yeah just give me
your quick like
one three sausages
sausage you eat it because and
there were no words at a certain point
yeah i saw him once and he did
he had nothing to say and we bumped into
each other and i was having coughing
ah coffee huh i was like yeah i'm having
kyle
it's good for you he's got caffeine to
wake you up
but it was crazy i just i do him as mr
positive because he never goes negative
i remember
he had a movie that didn't do well at
one point and they're interviewing him
on the today show or something
like they didn't get the box i know it
was fantastic let me tell you people are
enjoying it all over the world
but it was lower than the other ones
yeah but everybody's great you're
fantastic
i'm fantastic everything's fantastic and
when he was governor there'd be a fire
and he would come out and
there was a fire force fire and the the
fire police and the firemen came to it
with the hoses
they came with the horses and they
sprayed the water
and the fire's like it's out of here i
don't like this